- Oh my God.
(clapping and instrumental music)
- We're getting acupuncture today.
- Acupuncture.
- Acupuncture is based on energy
and it's based on harmonizing
the energy of the body.
I will be putting acupuncture needles
and acupuncture points to help
harmonize the body and
bring balance to the system.
- I'm very nervous when
it comes to needles.
So this'll be a good
day to conquer my fear.
- But he's not nervous when it comes
to being shirtless.
- (laughs) What a zinger!
- It's not gonna like make me react
weird or anything is it?
I'm not gonna.
- (laughs) What do you
thinks gonna happen?
- Just afraid I'll fart or something.
(relaxing piano music)
- So Imma feel your pulse now.
And that's one of the diagnostic tools
is feeling the pulse and
looking at the tongue.
- [Voiceover] What does
looking at the tongue tell you?
- The tongue is one of the only muscles
that you can see outside the body.
So when you look at the
tongue it can tell you
what's happening inside.
- Oh OK.
- Oh do you stick them in my head?
Oh my God.
Is there one in right now?
- [Acupuncturist] Yeah.
(relaxing piano music)
- Ryan what does it look like?
- Ah!
You have an antenna on your head.
- Oh my God. What is my life?
- It's weird like you
feel a little something
but it definitely doesn't hurt.
- Felt that a little bit.
Oh my God. (laughs)
- Oh my God you're gonna stick one there.
Fuck me.
- And how many needles will you use on me?
- Usually I don't put
in more than 20 or 30.
(relaxing piano music)
(plucky guitar music)
- Felt quite good.
I relaxed.
(laughs)
- I feel really relaxed.
I don't know if it's
just the placebo effect
but I feel very in my body.
- I feel very like chill.
I don't think I'm like on
the cloud nine that he is.
- I feel pretty sleepy.
But like in a good way
not like a tired way.
- I could see myself
going and doing it again
depending on the benefits that I feel.
- Let's see how I sleep
tonight. I'll let you know.
- I think Ryan's just sad that he had
to do this post interview with a shirt on.
Like I think that's
the only like (laughs).
- Here it comes. That train is never late.
Always on time.
(plucky instrumental music)